[Musica]
[Applauso]
Kenya
1978 un piccolo bambino biondo scorrazza
libero e molto felice intorno a una
piscina Dopo una mattinata passata coi
propri genitori a vedere quegli animali
che forse solo immaginava Quando la
mamma glieli leggeva dai libri a 3 anni
non l'aveva ancora molto bene chiaro
Come leggere bene e comunque era pieno
di quella carica dei Leoni dei
rinoceronti delle delle giraffe dei
leopardi e questa energia la scaricava
intorno alla piscina divertendosi un
sacco quando a un certo punto accade
l'imprevedibile
quel piccolo bambino biondo molto carino
molto piccolo si ferma davanti al bordo
della piscina Si tira giù i pantaloni e
fa la pipì in piscina i genitori erano
più 4-5 Met da quel piccolo bambino e il
padre e la madre Presi dal panico
cercavano di interrompere l'inevitabile
Purtroppo il bambino era già riuscito a
inquinare le acque del Resort E
nonostante tutto il padre cercò di
avvicinarsi e minimizzare i danni
leggende Dicono che quel bambino una
volta interrogato sul perché di questo
gesto abbastanza inconsiderato disse è
una piscina ci si può fare la pipì
dentro sono Federico Lera e sono il
bambino Biondo che ha fatto la pipì in
piscina in
Kenya evidentemente i miei genitori Già
all'età di 3 anni indico i miei genitori
proprio per il disagio che devono aver
provato Già all'età di 3 anni hanno
capito benissimo che non sarebbe stata
un'infanzia facile Eppure continuare in
una scelta consapevole e assai e di cui
sono assai grato di decidere di portarmi
sempre con loro perché quel primo
viaggio era l'inizio di una serie di
piccoli viaggi che mi regalarono un
bambino che andava sul tappeto volante
Anno dopo anno scopriva posti nuovi
gente nuova modi nuovi di vivere Sì
perché è un modo di viaggiare molto
particolare i miei genitori non amavano
le piscine ovviamente dopo il Kenya
preferivano portarmi in giro per vedere
le persone per vedere i posti per
assaggiare il cibo per parlare con
quelle persone che ovviamente negli
alberghi da cin stelle non c'erano a
parte che non ce li saremmo potuti
permettere ma poi non era quello il
senso del viaggiare il senso del
viaggiare è proprio portare un bambino
che vede le cose sui libri a vederle coi
propri occhi e quindi i paesi
diventarono sempre di più il modo di
conoscere le persone diventarono sempre
di più dalla Kenya alla Tunisia la
Tanzania al Marocco Cuba Repubblica
Dominicana Sri Lanka e e accumuli
persone accumulava energia accumulava
tradizioni accumulava qualcosa che era
fuori da quella bellissima bolla della
città di Sarzana dove sono nato e
cresciuto che era un posto privilegiato
mi rendevo conto perché c'era tutto
quello di cui avevo bisogno e c'era
anche per me la possibilità di viaggiare
di prendere un tappeto volante o meglio
un aereo e farmi portare dove più avevo
voglia di vedere vi ho detto che
l'infanzia era un momento chiaramente
difficile Ovviamente ho saltato i pezzi
peggiori della mia infanzia quelli dove
i miei genitori purtroppo hanno dovuto
sopportare all'età di se di 17 anni però
i miei genitori si resero conto che
anche l'adolescenza avanzata non sarebbe
stata da meno a quel punto della mia
vita presi una decisione non era più il
mondo che volevo scoprire non era più il
mondo che vedevo vedere con i miei
genitori ma volevo fare qualcosa di
molto più impegnativo qualcosa che mi
avrebbe dato sicuramente una strada
nella vita che mi avrebbe portato a
essere
felice volevo fare la rock
star Oggi sono qui Come vedete non Nella
presentazione non parlava di musica
quindi non sono riuscito nemmeno a fare
la Rockstar due fallimenti e Eppure
Eppure quella strada che mi ha
Ovviamente non era la mia non era la mia
perché non ho doti canore non ho doti
musicali Ho l'orecchio che fa
assolutamente schifo Non riesco a
riconoscere un sol quando me lo fanno
davanti o me lo scrivono mi impose
comunque un cambiamento da una parte
abbandonare il tappeto volante dei miei
genitori dall'altra parte cercare
comunque di entrare nel mondo della
musica e provarci quantomeno a trovare
qualche piccola nicchia dove inserirmi
Allora la chitarra e allora i Falo
abusivi sulla spiaggia allora le feste
di compleanno e allora i locali più
malfamati del nord Italia e in tutto
questo ovviamente si partiva viste le
mie doti appunto Dalla Canzone del sole
di Battisti che per chi ha minimamente
suonato la chitarra sa che è la BC Cioè
se non riesce a suonare quella è un
problema passando per gli 883 Sì sono
del 75 l' 883 li ho vissuti bene
e per cercare di fare comunque la
persona con i gusti Pop Ma poi c'è stato
il secondo intoppo dopo la piscina
Fabrizio De André Fabrizio De André
perché l'ho iniziato a suonare
ovviamente lo dico con tutto il cuore
per voi perché non posso nascondere la
verità l'ho iniziato a suonare per darmi
un tono volevo sembrare quell'
intelligente di quelli che suonavano gli
883 e l'orgoglio igure e il mio modo
comunque di essere legato alla mia terra
mi portavano a privilegiare questo
tentativo invece che Guccini ovviamente
a quel punto però De André ha fatto un
danno ha fatto un danno perché se De
André lo suoni poi lo devi leggere poi
lo devi ascoltare e allora ho scoperto
un altro tappeto ho ho scoperto un
tappeto dove le persone vanno sotto Ho
scoperto delle storie ho scoperto delle
immagini ho scoperto dei personaggi che
la voglia di ordine e disciplina della
società tende a mettere o ai margini a
infilare sotto il tappeto e allora
ragionavo del fatto che io avevo un
tappeto che mi portava dove volevo e
c'erano persone che avevano un tappeto
dove venivano infilate sotto perché non
erano normali non avevano quella
capacità di essere parte di quella bolla
felice che ha la società e tutte questi
marginati tutte queste persone che
vivono per strada tutte queste persone
che Fabrizio de andrei Don gall hanno
conosciuto e hanno aiutato finivano
sotto il tappeto il mio tappeto volante
mi ha fatto fare altri due viaggi prima
di dimetterlo completamente mi ha
portato a Parma dove ho potuto studiare
giurisprudenza molto lentamente per
affinare meglio la tecnica e la città di
Genova la città di Genova dove sono
diventato avvocato dove ho fatto il mio
esame e dove ho avuto un maestro che mi
ha insegnato la differenza fra fare
l'avvocato e essere avvocato
a quel punto avevo degli strumenti avevo
i privilegi che avevo avuto perché io
non ringrazierò mai abbastanza i miei
genitori che mi hanno permesso di fare
quello che volevo fare cioè studiare
quello che volevo studiare anche dopo di
potermi permettere di arrivare a parlare
a voi di quello che adoro fare perché
quello che faccio oggi nella vita è
quello che mi piace veramente è quello
che mi dà soddisfazione dal mattino alla
sera e allora a Parma ho imparato e a
Genova ho imparato a conoscere Come
applicare tutte quelle regole regole che
mettevano le persone sotto da un certo
punto di vista sotto quel tappeto e io
volevo iniziare a capire come quelle
regole potessero essere usate in maniera
diversa cioè essere regole che usavano
venivano usate dalle persone per aiutare
le persone e allora mi ricordo la prima
storia che vi vorrei raccontare la
storia dell'uomo delle biciclette L'uomo
delle biciclette è un signore anziano
che magari qualcuno di voi ha già visto
e conosciuto perché passeggiando per il
centro di Spezia spesso lo si può
incontrare lo si può incontrare seduto
davanti al civico col suo banchetto lo
si può incontrare magari sotto i portici
Quando il tempo non è esattamente dei
migliori e potete vedere questo signore
che con le mani delle mani grandi delle
mani che si vede che hanno lavorato
tanto nella vita prendono dei fili di
ferro li modellano li girano li rigirano
li fanno diventare qualcosa li colorano
e poi diventano delle biciclette delle
piccole biciclette dei piccoli
capolavori che questa persona in non più
di 5 minuti riesce a creare io
personalmente non ho idea di come
poterlo fare in anche in due giorni di
lavoro lui dalla mente ha tirato fuori
queste biciclette di vari tipi di vari
colori e io mi ricordo ancora le volte
che lo vedevo perché poi vedi i bambini
che ci si fermano davanti lo guardano e
pensano che è un miracolo quello che sta
facendo e per me che con la manualità
faccio schifo è effettivamente un
miracolo un miracolo è riuscire a creare
con la mente qualcosa che può essere un
regalo per una persona una sorpresa per
un bambino Beh L'uomo delle biciclette
ha una storia L'uomo delle biciclette
prima di tutto è jugoslavo che sia
chiaro Non gli interessa la divisione
paesi paesini Nazioni nazion cine lui è
jugoslavo se lo fermate e gli chiedete
Di dov'è lui è jugoslavo e ci tiene
molto tantissimo anche perché lui è nato
in un piccolo paese della Jugoslavia che
al momento dello scoppio della guerra è
stato praticamente completamente reso al
suolo addirittura anche l'ufficio
anagrafe ha perso tutta la
documentazione possibile non esiste più
traccia di gran parte delle persone nate
in quel paesino è scappato ovviamente
dalla guerra ha viaggiato per il sud
dell'Italia Scusate il sud dell'Europa è
sceso in Italia è andato nel sud del
Piemonte imperi e poi si è stabilito a
Spezia Io ricordo ancora il giorno che
l'ho incontrato nella stanza di un
eh associazione di un posto dove Grazie
all'aiuto di alcuni operatori sociali
incontravo delle persone che potevano
aver bisogno di un aiuto legale mi
ricordo che si è seduto davanti a me mi
ha iniziato a raccontare la sua storia
dalla Jugoslavia e l'ho dovuto ascoltare
ho dovuto ascoltare perché poi mi sono
reso conto dov'era dov'era l'intoppo
perché aveva bisogno di me questa
persona questa per aveva bisogno di me
perché aveva perso
l'identità perdere L'identità è
abbastanza facile Noi diamo per scontati
carte di identità diamo per scontati
patenti diamo per scontati permessi di
soggiorno diamo per scontato un sacco di
cose ma se tu vieni da un piccolo
paesino della Jugoslavia che viene Raso
al suolo per la guerra sei in Italia
perdi la patente perdi la carta
d'identità del tuo paese perdi il
passaporto e non hai altro non hai più
un identità e se dopo aver perso tutto
arrivano anche se mesi in cui tu non
riesci più a lavorare non riesci a
rinnovare un permesso di soggiorno tu
non puoi neanche più lavorare non puoi
lavorare non puoi avere una casa non
puoi avere una casa non puoi avere la
base di una
sopravvivenza grazie a alcune persone
L'uomo delle biciclette è venuto da me
Io ho dovuto chiedere aiuto a altre
persone e siamo arrivati fino al
tribunale civile di Genova per aiutare
questa persona a riconoscersi a
riconoscere la propria cittadinanza
riconoscere i propri diritti e dopo un
buon periodo di tempo L'uomo delle
biciclette è tornato a essere albino è
tornato a essere quell'uomo che è
partito da un piccolo paese della
Jugoslavia per arrivare fino da noi e
ora Albino continua a fare le biciclette
perché non lo abbandonerebbe mai quel
lobby che oggi un hobby perché un tempo
è stato solo la sua sopravvivenza e
allora mi chiedo io posso fare qualcosa
da solo per cambiare le persone per
cambiare e aiutare le persone per dare
un modo a queste persone che sono sotto
il tappeto perché non hanno diritti a
tornare ad avere i diritti io non parlo
di normalità perché la normalità è
quella che forse proprio non cercano
perché si rendono conto che la normalità
è quella che li ha messi sotto il
tappeto No da solo non lo posso fare
perché io sono una piccola rotellina in
un ingranaggio io ho potuto aiutare
Albino perché c'è stato qualcuno prima
di me che l'ha trovato per strada e gli
ha chiesto chi era ha cercato di capire
se era un problema legato al suo modo di
essere un problema legale un problema
medico ci deve essere Qual qualcuno che
ascolta ci deve essere qualcuno che
scopre ci deve essere qualcuno che sa
cosa fare ma sono tutti piccoli
ingranaggi devono funzionare molto bene
insieme perché altrimenti Albino anche
in quei mesi che cui abbiamo aiutato non
si sarebbe riuscita a trovare nella
condizione in cui adesso ci vuole
qualcosa che parta dall'ascolto delle
persone e la smetta di meravigliarsi
davanti alle persone che rubano il pane
sempre per citare de Andre perché è una
cosa che ci viene insegnato cioè
qualcuno che ai margini della società
può essere essere a volte pericoloso
qualcosa che non conosciamo ma chissà
chi è chissà da dove viene Chissà dove
vuole andare ecco lui veniva dalla
Jugoslavia ha perso il lavoro ha perso
il permesso di soggiorno ha perso
l'identità bastava ascoltarlo lo
potevamo ascoltare prima non lo so Io so
solo che è successo è la cosa che più mi
ha dato felicità in un momento in cui
comunque la mia professione Diventava
pesante Perché fare l'avvocato è bello
essere avvocato è bello però a volte
devi trovare un motivo per continuare a
fare una professione e trovare il modo
per migliorare il mondo io sono stato
privilegiato io ho potuto fare la Pip in
Kenya a 3 anni non credo che molti lo
possano fare nel curriculum cioè nel
curriculum non lo ho ma lo posso
raccontare a voi ma non è facile trovare
chi ha avuto queste possibilità chi ha
avuto la possibilità di formarsi una
mente fuori anche da delle piccole
realtà che sono
meravigliose E a proposito di realtà
meravigliose vorrei raccontarvi un'altra
storia perché poi il mio lavoro la mia
vita è fatta di storia
è fatta di persone è fatta di incontri è
fatta di
ascolto e una delle ultime storie che ho
incontrato è una delle peggiori è una di
quelle che più mi ha segnato dentro è la
storia di Mercy una ragazza nigeriana
che ora una circa un 20 anni che quando
era ancora minorenne è stata convinta a
venire in Europa è stata convinta perché
lei era una parrucchiera bravissima e
nel suo paesino ovviamente non avevamo
molte possibilità una ragazza nigeriana
nel sud della Nigeria non è che sia il
massimo per le aspirazioni di vita e di
neanche di guadagno Allora c'è stato
qualcuno che ha detto guarda Mercy
Secondo me con le tue doti Se decidi di
andare in Europa vedrai che troverai
assolutamente il modo di fare anche lei
come l'uomo delle biciclette con le mani
le tue creazioni avere un futuro
migliore di quello dove sei adesso una
zona dove per bere un buon bicchiere
d'acqua puoi fare anche 5-20 km a piedi
per cercare un posto dove il petrolio
non abbia inquinato le falde acquifere
Mersi ci ha creduto ovviamente Beh chi
non ci crederebbe vivo in un posto dove
ci sono discretamente parecchi problemi
mi dicono che se vado in Europa posso
fare la parrucchiera a bomba avrei fatto
pure
io il problema è che le persone che
l'hanno accolta dopo tutta la trafila
tutta la trafila del Sub Sariano Sara
Libia liesi Libia mare mare mezzi
naufragi eccetera arrivata in Italia non
l'hanno portata a fare la parrucchiera
l'hanno portata in Campania
l'hanno sfruttata l'hanno picchiata
l'hanno rinchiusa l'hanno rapita l'hanno
ripicchettare per
strada Napoli Caserta Salerno Benevento
Isernia
Campobasso non me li ricordo tutti ma
c'è stata un'altra piccola rotellina a
un certo punto della vita di Mercy che
l'ha portata nel sud del Piemonte una
piccola rotellina che io non conosco non
l'ho mai conosciuta Non ne ho idea di
chi sia ma lei è arrivata nel sud del
Piemonte dal Sud del Piemonte è arrivata
a Genova e anche lì non so come c'è
stato qualcuno che nel mezzo di questo
tragitto l'ha portata a incontrarmi un
giorno in una stanzetta del tribunale di
Genova quinto piano stanza avvocati
piccolissima lei si è presentato con
questi neri occhi giganti neri che
guardavano solo qua guardavano le mani
dondolava guardava le mani non mi
guardava non aveva il coraggio non aveva
aveva la timidezza aveva la vergogna io
non non ve lo posso dire però non
guardava me e aveva in mano quattro
fogli quattro fogli scritti a penna che
senza dire niente mi ha
consegnato era la sua
storia sono le quattro pagine più dure
che abbia mai letto come se mi dessero
continuamente pugni in faccia Io li ho
salvati sul cellulare perché ogni tanto
li guardo sono pugni in faccia sono
pugni nello stomaco sono quando ti
prende le fitte al fegato Scusate di qua
quando ti prende le fitte al fegato
quando ti rendi conto che sei talmente
arrabbiato da voler uscire e picchiare
la prima persona che trovi per strada
perché devi punire qualcuno per quello
che un essere umano ha
sentito però io non glielo potevo far
vedere tutto questo perché avevo paura
che fosse mal interpretato cioè che
fosse lei a percepire che era lei la
persona sbagliata che io stavo
giudicando lei ma io non giudicavo lei
io giudicavo che le aveva fatto fare
tutta quella strada per poi renderla
quello che era io le guardavo le
cicatrici sul viso le cicatrici sulle
orecchie guardavo quegli occhi che
continuavano a fissare il tavolo e mi
chiedevo perché e non lo so il perché io
non lo so So solo che c'è stato un
ingranaggio che l'ha portata nel sud del
Piemonte un ingranaggio che l'ha portata
a Genova e io ho fatto la mia piccola
parte perché poi siamo stati insieme a
delle persone molto competenti quando si
parla di questi fenomeni che l'hanno
aiutata a cambiare la propria vita io
dove oggi Mercy non ne ho assolutamente
idea Non so nemmeno se si chiami ancora
Mercy Io so che l'ho salutata
abbracciandola Un giorno a Genova
e so che è andata via da Genova non so
dove sia so che sta bene perché me
l'hanno detto perché le persone che
l'hanno aiutato a andare via Mi hanno
detto che sta bene e tant'è questo mi
basta So di essere stato un piccolo
ingranaggio che ha cambiato la vita di
quest'altra persona con il mio lavoro
con quello che non pensavo fosse
utile magari quando studiavo ma ho fatto
la mia piccola parte e allora prima di
salutarvi vorrei tornare all'inizio del
viaggio che abbiamo fatto a quel punto
di svolta in cui forse ho deciso per la
prima volta di cambiare quello che stavo
facendo e allora vorrei raccontarvi o
meglio leggervi perché non la riesco a
ripetere a memoria una frase che
Fabrizio De André normalmente usava alla
fine dei propri concerti dei propri
spettacoli Rivolgendosi a parte del
pubblico e dicendo
che tutto quello che avete ascoltato
fino adesso è assolutamente falso così
come sono assolutamente veri gli ideali
e i sentimenti che mi hanno portato a
scrivere queste cose e a cantarle ma con
gli ideali e coi sentimenti si
costruiscono delle realtà Sognate la
realtà quella vera È quella che ci
aspetta fuori dalle porte del teatro e
per modificarla se vogliamo modificarla
c'è bisogno di gesti concreti e
[Applauso]
reali e io vi
chiedo Siete pronti a uscire stasera
dalle porte di quel teatro e diventare
dei piccoli ingranaggi per cambiare la
vita delle
[Applauso]
persone
l